was deandre swift underrated underneath
the star can he get the star
[Music]
be a star deandre
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show
where professional athletes get to
improve their video game ratings and
today we have the scintillating the
super the spectacular deandre swift of
the detroit lions
[Applause]
i'm watching you last year
you can run faster than anybody you can
catch better than anybody how is the gun
though how is the arm what kind of
throne do we have i got an arm you do i
do that okay i looked it up
you had one throw with the lions you had
one throw in college
how many of those did you complete zero
yes
do you know your madden ratings for
throwing i don't okay
i'm gonna tell you okay but i have the
plug i brought him here to boost your
ratings let's get clinton here clint
look how official he looks
this is the madden ratings adjustment
goodness
what do you think your short throw
accuracy is probably like 50 a 50 50.
clint what is it it's a 30. it's a 30.
okay okay he looked that way because he
didn't want it to believe it so he's
actually tied at 53rd among all nfl
running backs 53rd we need to change
that we need to change that we need to
change that let's see what we got today
so you need to see accuracy today i need
to see accuracy okay are you ready to
show him what it takes to boost that
rating i'm ready to show you i'm ready
yeah all right good luck show us what
you got yes sir
all right deandre we have a two minute
drill set up we got pinatas about five
yards deep
you hit one you keep moving the more you
hit the more your rating goes up so
whenever you're ready
he's going for the pig
he's getting his balance
bang
[Music]
next one
now the donkey drills the donkey and he
opens him in half
[Music]
the unicorn
boom open him up
[Music]
he hit shamu in the fin
underneath the star can he get the star
he can't hit this star
be a star deandre
all right now he's moving down to the
cowboy booth
he's going right he's going right
there he goes and he opens the boot and
now it is just the t-rex
drills tyrannosaurus rex
[Music]
we have moved our way down the field you
cannot miss in the red zone you're going
for the tiki man i want explosions
[Music]
whoa
first hit
made his way down the field got it done
tiki man exploded how did it feel
overall feel good had to get warmed up a
little bit but once i got going it was
good i felt like some of the throws and
early we were going low and to the right
when did it start clicking for you
probably about after the third throw i
had to get a rhythm but uh definitely
was low to the right had to pick it up a
little bit this man has been writing
notes he has been very meticulous
so clint are you ready
i'm ready okay
come over here give me some shade
sorry let me just get your overall feel
of what we saw
actually pretty accurate deandre you
were able to hit every target and you
didn't hit him on the first try but you
hit every target man
okay we wanted to improve his throwing
ratings throw accuracy short because all
the passes we made today were
short
variety that's actually going up five
points from a 30 to a 35 that puts you
inside of the top 40 for all nfl running
backs that's a bump of 13 spots progress
i guess
and more importantly now i get to ask
you the question was deandre swift
underrated deandre swift was underrated
and passive i appreciate that
appreciate that
[Music]
you